okay let's give it another go against
the Beast I'm going to try to get a
closed position for starters let's see
if C4 will be played no I think with
this move order E3 I'll have an easier
time getting my Bishop outside of the
pawn
chain my only question is what Square to
go to F5 or pin the
Knight I'm going to go with the PIN and
maybe provoke some weaknesses okay
support my Center meet Queen here with
Queen
here
okay support my Center Queen B3 Queen B6
I've had good positions from this
variation
before so I'm liking this start so far
they're going to go in for my light
squirt
Bishop not much I could do about that I
need to challenge this guy right
away otherwise F4 can be a pain in fact
maybe this is already a moment to
pause if Knight B to D7 I think after H4
I'm in some
trouble yeah I think I have to challenge
the Knight with Knight on
F Knight B to D7 H4 Knight takes Knight
Pawn takes my knight is
hit and then when he
moves h 5 is going to trap my Bishop I
could play here but then there's
F3 so I think I need to challenge this
Knight with this guy I'm going to go
with that is there something other than
that I don't think so I got to go with
this Knight takes Bishop it is so at
least I have some play on the H well I
don't know about play but I have an half
open H file to maybe work
with now I wonder if I should get this
Knight back into
F6 or something else like where where
else is he going to go
H he could be kicked with G5 but then I
can maybe make use of this F5 Square I
think I need to get him back in play so
let's get him back to
F6 all right he's getting kicked if he
goes here he's going to get stranded so
this looks very awkward I realize but uh
I think I still have control over this
position nothing's blowing open until
that move
happens okay
hm this could be tricky for sure now
actually if Pawn takes Knight takes how
do I develop my knight to E7 how do I
get this guy
working without blocking in this D6
Square I can't even grab here because of
Queen takes so H I think I got to
capture in this direction I can't allow
this Knight to get that
square and there might be already some
ideas of sacrific is
here
H Bishop here and then Knight
here this is going to get very scary
there's going to be a sacrifice
happening here if I'm not
careful all right let's go with maybe a
queen trade right
now just to make sure there's not any
sacrifices here Pon takes all
right
um okay now I'm going to consider Bishop
here and then Knight
here actually maybe something else let's
get this Knight developed if I played I
have to be careful of B4 B5
ideas let me do this so that I could
finally free up my Rook I have to
prepare for this type of
advance I don't have good squares for my
Knights just yet I'd really like to have
dark Square Bishops
exchanged
H okay could I manage a dark Square
Bishop
exchange not the easiest thing to do for
sure this bishop could be who knows how
he could be activated F3
G4 I'm thinking about Knight E7 to
C8 I'll go for that need to I'll
definitely need to move him twice anyway
so okay the king's gonna go to G2 all
right well this is a start Knight C8 and
at least Bishop here I don't think it
would be so stupid to play this because
it would give up this
Square we're going to test it out let's
try this anyhow Pawn push
okay that was kind of
expected uh for a moment I was thinking
Rook H4 and Bishop here but after an
exchange King G3 my Rook would be
trapped so that's not
good hm
H what could I do need to be a little
bit careful with this bishop here
playing a knight to
B6
uh as soon as he's not defended there's
this D5 break with
Tempo
H if I kingside Castle there's going to
be H4
H5 I'm a bit stuck here I wonder if I
should throw my knight to
E7 uh
[Music]
uh yeah let's go with to Knight
E7 fight for control over D5 okay now if
I Queens this is kind of tough now if I
kingside Castle there's H5 if I
queenside Castle well there might be
this anyhow regardless if I Castle or
not H5 is always a way to break down the
light Square Pawn
structure and open up the position to
the benefit of the bishop pair and of
course the white Rooks
so if I queenside Castle am I am I going
to get hammered here with Pawn takes or
Bishop takes Pawn takes Rook
takes I don't think so I think I have to
go in this direction anticipating this
anyhow okay so got to
take
and you know it's also a bit of a pain
here well I'm pretty sure I have to do
this
but when I do this the drawback is H6 so
The Rook might be planting up
here
okay um anticipating Rook here takes
Pawn takes how could I disrupt the
coordination between the bishop and pawn
there's not really a way I could control
this H6 Square so easily Knight G8
disconnects my Rooks Bishop f8 similar
H I'm still finding trouble here having
difficulty getting my Knights to
Reliable homes there are no holes in the
white position these pawns here are too
good striking at it with
E5 man it's kind
of it's a tough spot if I if I try to
get some homes for my
Knights then I'm also opening up the
position for the Bishops and if I don't
well I don't have homes for my
Knights uh let's
see I'm not
sure all right this is what I'm going to
try I'm going to try this and kind of
sneak my king over in this direction I'm
expecting Rook H6 yeah I thought you
would do
that
and it's pretty farfetched well let's
consider capturing right
now this might not be a bad idea
actually Rook takes and then Pawn push
with Bishop
here that pawn is going to be
loose tough to hang on to a black Pawn
on this F4 Square Rook takes Pawn takes
push with Bishop
F4
H all right I'm going to I'm going to
come over in this direction I'm
expecting Rook here and then I'm going
to be forced into capturing anyhow but
I'm I'm happy to see that that Rook is
no longer
there and I think before it's too late I
got to get my I keep pressure
here
and oh man that Knight is going to kill
me oh he's going to kill me okay where
do to go I think he needs to stay here
on this diagonal I'm going throw my
knight into here oh not so fast
no you won't throw your knight in there
so fast so I need to get out of the pin
that's for sure I'm happy to have these
squares but I'm expecting
something something pretty quick here
that the computer could be
doing uh let's
see got to stop that pawn from pushing I
believe that kind of gives me some hope
believe it or not seeing that move gives
me a little little bit of Hope because I
think to myself what is it doing it
seems like it's just a passing move so
what's wrong with Knight
here and then like Bishop here
even okay what's that tricky Knight up
to no
good he is definitely up to no
good
okay
h
uh
tricky Bishop f8 Knight here into
here see if I do this there's going to
always be this night move here can I can
I work around that though
somehow oh this is tough this is very
tough this is so tough okay where where
do I go here what's he doing that's
fantastic he's doing absolutely
nothing
um I don't even know how to get him
doing
something let's try here I have this
Square cover that's very
important all right let's try here I
guess oh I could try and get my knight
here okay he's he needs to
go I can't deal with that no way how
does how does uh how does white break
through
here
uh wait a second Knight here to here am
I not just getting that pawn he going to
come up with
something um I don't know if I want to
do that no I think it's in I think
Bishop takes and then the king's going
to be entering somehow I think I need to
try and and come up with just a long
fight and a blockade
strategy I don't think white has any
successful Pawn
breaks I think I keep I need to keep my
knight
trained right where he's at
there let me go back actually I think
the king needs to move oh the king's
coming all the way over here oh
man
okay um
maybe I could get my king to
H7 wow that's going to take
forever that's GNA take
forever uh I'm gonna give it a go though
why
not why
not not liking my
decision
um let's try it what do you have to
lose Rook here
all right let's go for
it let's go for it and then Rook here am
I missing
anything
okay I feel a little bit more
comfortable actually having my king is
the
blockader living on the edge okay I'm
def defending my base points here I'd be
okay with the an exchange now okay this
is this this I feel com oh Pawn push oh
Pawn push is going to kill me no I have
a way to blockade this
position Rook trade
yes what is this computer
doing um I should have a draw Pawn
push it can't make progress and neither
can
I
H oh I should probably
move I should probably move you know
what the king sneak over here but no is
there a way that I can make progress
here I don't think so it's offering a
draw I'm going to take a draw we cannot
I cannot make progress I don't think
either can make progress here this
Bishop's not going to go anywhere if I
take it it's going to be connected past
pwn oo I'm actually a little bit happy
with my decision only at one point in
this game to be perfectly honest this
one right here
the decision
to not make this Knight F5
move coming up here where is it oh when
we had this exchange where it was two
Knights versus two Bishops around this
point I didn't see any way that white
could
make a successful Pawn break and I think
if I jumped in here that would have been
very
bad because black because white would be
quick to transfer a rook over here and
then get in here to this d8
Square somehow and even even have the
king sneak over another another
important factor with keeping the Knight
on this D5 Square I didn't reference it
when I was playing but I I thought about
it it's that it guards this B6 Square so
having some long king walk over here
there's not really a way to get into
this Square not at least without getting
rid of my knight on the D5 square but if
I am to allow Bishop takes Knight in
this in this position here Knight here
Bishop
takes I don't even know what the correct
direction is even if I go like this
there might even be Rook activity along
the G file
but capturing like this I just saw a way
that white is going to be able to
activate that Rook somehow combined with
the pawn break maybe sneaking over here
I think it was important that I did not
make that Knight F5 move and I guess at
the end there I what neither side was
really able to make progress
that final position that uh yeah I could
go back to it like this here in this
final position neither of us could have
made progress no great Pawn breaks for
either side
here oh this isn't the final position
but once we have the Rooks traded and my
king over here blockading that pawn
there wasn't really a way to make
progress okay um I guess I'll take the
the drawn result the computer I've
noticed when it comes to to the bishop
versus knight situation if it has a bad
Bishop uh that's where it could be a bit
vulnerable and this might have been
a uh one of the vulnerable moments of
the computer going into an
endgame with a good night versus bad
Bishop though my king of course was tied
down there defending the pawn anyhow
feel free to leave some feedback and let
me know what you thought and as always I
hope you got something out of this video
take care
bye